ce sont ressentis de plus en plus aux
quatre coins du québec
la passion pour le pcot bas est
contagieuse les gens sont emballés
stocks commencent à jouer
oh la la c'est plein ça continue c'est
un sport qui qui est tellement agréable
à jouer
le pcot base je joue principalement en
double sur un terrain de dimension
similaire à celui de badminton les
mouvements rappelle le tennis et la
vitesse des échanges le tennis de table
des caractéristiques qui rendent le
sport accessible aux débutants
le terrain est moins grain la raquette
est légère le service se fait par en
dessous de ce fait peur de suffixes tout
ça c'est des choses qui facilite
l'apprentissage en outaouais
l'engouement du pic au bal ce métier 12
mois par année
quelques terrains de tennis de la ville
de gatineau comporte aussi les lignes
délimitant la surface de jeu du pic au
bal leur nombre est toutefois
insuffisant pour répondre à la demande
des 300 membres de l'association
régionale est ce qu on aimerait en soit
c'est que tous les terrains soient ligne
ep cobalt est nu c'est certain et que
des terrains qu'ils soient vraiment
spécifique au 6 octobre des demandes
répétées aux quatre coins de la province
le président de la fédération québécoise
crois qu'avec les moyens nécessaires le
sport a le potentiel d'être aussi
populaire ici qu'aux états unis
plus de trois millions de joueurs y
pratique le pcot baisse selon les
données de l'association américaine
l'important au super bowl de la
population puisqu'ils jouent fait gruger
les municipalités explique russ julie
foucault a remédié à la situation en se
procurant son propre filet la gatinoise
s'est initiée aux peco ballet ya cinq
ans lors de voyage en floride pour
visiter ses parents si le sport est
pratiqué principalement par des gens de
55 ans et plus elle croit que les plus
jeunes ont beaucoup à y gagner quatre
jours et cobol que la balle arrive à
toutes les deux secondes
tout porte à penser à d'autres choses ça
ça t'amène transports factices
c'est quand même actif physique on a
chaud puis ça fait du bien mentalement
certains trouvent même un bonus
supplémentaire ce que je mange et un
contre la personne de vue sont bien
contents preuve que le pico balle et
plein de rebondissements ici qui me
liait à radio-canada gatineau